the man accused of murdering five people
at a newspaper in Annapolis Maryland
made his alleged intentions clear before
the deadly rampage
police say the Jared Ramos sent
threatening letters to a courthouse the
Maryland Court of Appeals and a law
office just a few hours before the
attack the details in the letters are
very disturbing signed by suspected
gunman Jared Ramos the haunting letters
reveal he was on his way to the Capitol
Gazette with the objective of killing
every person present a copy of the
letters was sent to the paper's former
executive editor Tom Marquardt he
previously told CBS news about Ramos his
years of threats against the paper the
police had visited him but came away
with a conclusion that there wasn't
enough there to really find criminal
charges against him Ramos has letters
also referenced his failed defamation
lawsuit against the Capitol Gazette in
2012 he sued the newspaper after it
published a story about his harassment
of a former female classmate the suit
was eventually thrown out and an appeals
court refused to hear the case in his
letter to the appeals court he writes if
this is how the Maryland judiciary
operates the law now means nothing you
were too cowardly to confront those lies
and this is your receipt I told you so
he also sent a letter to Judge Charles
Moylan one of the appellate judges in
charge of the case welcome mr. Moylan to
your unexpected legacy you should have
died my brother was a person of
phenomenal grace last night more than
500 family members and friends gathered
to remember editor Rob hyacinth one of
the five capital Gazette employees who
died in the attack my dad is my best
friend he is my hero he is my strength
he is the purest form of happiness I've
ever felt in my life the American
Society of news editors has called for a
moment of silence in all newsrooms on
Thursday exactly one week after the
shooting annapolis mayor Gavin Buckley
says he put in a request to the White
House to lower American flags to half
staff across the country he says the
president didn't
his request we've reached out to the
White House about the mayor's request
and have not heard back a lot of warning
signs there you haven't it's not clear
it's not clear at the if the the editors
of the paper got the letters before the
deadly attack was was was carried out
he's sent the letters but did do they
receive the letters in time to read them
that still isn't clear to me right